get ready you cool cats and kittens from
tiger king
to dancing queen carol baskin is
officially joining the new season of
dancing with the stars
she's dancing away from big cat rescue
all the way to the ballroom
even ringing her cat it's the tiger
queen herself
harold baskin the cast of season 29 was
announced on good morning america
wednesday
hey all you cool cats and kittens yeah
get ready for a treat all you
cool cats and kittens because the 59
year old big cat rescue ceo gave
us a little taste of her moves rocking
her signature flower crown
and dancing with a tiger okay fine not a
real tiger a toy tiger
and yes i'm serious
carol said that she hopes the show helps
people see her in a new light
the biggest thing for me is that the
longer my partner and i can stay
in the running and in the competition it
will keep the cat's forefront
in the viewer's eye and to me that was
where tiger king missed the ball
of course carol found global fame this
year thanks to the netflix series
documenting her feud with now imprisoned
zoo owner joe exotic it really should
have been focused on the animals and so
i'm hoping
dancing with the stars will do that i am
competitive but i'm competitive with
myself i want to do the very best that i
can possibly do
the full cast lineup is stacked it
includes backstreet boys aj mclean
former nfl player vernon davis
former disney star skye jackson olympic
figure skater johnny weir
former bachelorette caitlyn bristow nba
superstar charles oakley
the real host genie mai one day at a
time starred justina machado
desperate housewives alum jessie metcalf
selling sunset's krishell staus
actress anne heish the head coach from
netflix's cheer monica aldama
catfish host neve shulman and rapper
nelly but i gotta be honest here i think
carol's gonna steal the show we're kind
of popular
of course this season tyra banks joins
the show as the new host
lights camera action back in july the
supermodel turned businesswoman dished
about her new gig
on gma i am excited about
hosting and executive producing getting
in there
live tv you never know what happens on
live tv and
she teased this okay let's just keep
this real
it is gonna be so next level get ready
cause it's gonna be different
former host tom bergeron as well as
co-host aaron andrews were not asked to
return for the show's upcoming season
hosting is pretty cushy last year the tv
personality opened up to et
about being with the series since its
premiere way back in 2005.
it's been a great a great surprise in my
career to have that show
i think i just turned 50 when it
launched in 05
so that's not usually the place in a
career where the biggest thing
in your career happens you know that's
usually where
you're kind of going okay how do i how
do i scale this into retirement
but it's been just an amazing uh an
amazing surprise
and in may et spoke with longtime judge
carrie ananaba about what to expect in
the new season
we've been around this long because we
try to
evolve and keep up and keep it fresh and
interesting and keep the best parts of
the show for those who love the best
parts
and add new parts for people who haven't
seen it or haven't
or or getting bored
you